it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we reveal the cultural
stories of the day and for that we turn
to Fox News contributor Raymond Arroyo
all right Raymond Biden finally sat for
an interview was it stormy
yeah yeah it was with the Weather
Channel which makes sense Laura remember
Hunter's lawyer said about Biden's
conversations with his son's business
partners this
approximately 20 times over the course
of 10-year relationship
um Hunter may have put his father on the
the phone with any number of different
people and they never once spoke about
any business dealings it was all casual
conversation niceties the weather
you see Biden's an expert on the weather
but apparently not on the seven wonders
of the world
your Grand Canyon one of the Earth's
nine wonders wonders of the world
literally
think of that there's a you know it's
amazing
yeah it's amazing because the Grand
Canyon is not one of the nine wonders of
the world it is not even one of the
seven it's considered one of the seven
natural wonders of the world then the
president sat for his interview with the
Weather Channel and the forecast for him
Laura was partly cloudy
power grid is where people say we not my
neighborhood these big high tension
wires that carry the electricity long
distances for example we're now
transmitting over those lines on the
East Coast we're planting solar I mean
the wind power coming off the shores
okay but the power grid those that
electricity is going through these lines
When Storms Come and knock them down the
forest catch fires
I I think the barometric pressure just
dropped for Biden there just said the
Doppler isn't quite hitting him I don't
know and you saw the note card lore he
had all of his notes written out but
what is he saying the power lines are
carrying solar but they fall and burn
the force how is this climate friendly
by the way what he was really there to
do was to declare all the area around
the Grand Canyon a National Monument so
uranium mining would stop that means
anything with nuclear power yep yeah
well it's a big gift to Kazakhstan which
happened to be the site of one of Hunter
Biden's favorite oligarchs that well
just funneled a little bit of money to
him
well the Weather Channel interview
continued and a mental Nor'easter struck
are you prepared to declare a national
emergency with respect to climate change
I've already done that it see it is the
existential threat to humanity
so you've already declared that National
Emergency well in the practice oh thanks
appreciate it
the president did not declare a National
Climate emergency lore which activist
claim would allow him to unilaterally
stop oil production and exploration
that'll really work maybe he can create
energy by killing bugs he seems very
good at that
well that's what they want to do so
maybe in a second Biden term should he
be re-elected that's exactly what will
happen it'll be a race racism emergency
a climate emergency and throw in a new
pandemic just for good measure all right
there's also concern Raymond back at the
White House over Coke gate not of the
soda variety a report surface citing
three security sources that the cocaine
belonged to someone in the Biden family
orbit one of the German Shepherds
perhaps but but now the Secret Service
is claiming that the report is false
they don't know who transported the coke
into the White House and there are no
fingerprints on the bag according to the
FBI lab you know Laura this is going to
be another Supreme Court League Story
the investigation is going to drag on
and they hope the public forgets but you
know images like this are hard to forget
and whatever uh you'll see it in a
second whatever's happening there uh
Hunter Biden is flying high on that
balcony on July 4th he's doing all kinds
of strange Antics I I don't know if that
uh well if that you know adds up but
we'll see
well the question is did he inhale all
right um there's an update on the lizzo
story because America and inquiring
minds want to know Jay-Z canceled his
made in America Music Festival where
lizzo was to headline and some are
speculating because of the charges
against the singer is that right yeah
well lizzo's in plus size trouble
tonight the free dancers charging her
with fat shaming and a sexually charged
environment listen
was I pressured to touch a new performer
yes was I brought into a private meeting
where I was kind of interrogated having
to share very personal personal things
about myself regarding my weight yes she
actually balled up her fist like this to
me she started cracking her Knuckles and
she was like you're so effing lucky that
basically I'm not gonna hit you with her
best friend who is also one of the
dancers had to jump out of the couch and
physically hold her back from coming and
hitting me
now Laura now lizzo is saying these
charges are not true these are
disgruntled employees but now six more
employees have come forward with
accusations of sexual harassment against
lizzo and considering her Instagram
Antics this doesn't look too good I mean
the truth hurts even for the big girls
if you know what I mean oh no okay turn
that over there yeah no no that's a
Raymond I wish I cared about the lizzo
story I truly wish I cared about it
Laurie even I have a big I have a big
cover announced I need to show a cover
reveal my new Lincoln book uh the
Magnificent Mischief of Tad Lincoln the
cover is dropping today you can
pre-order it now it's an amazing story
of mercy and forgiveness and shows a
Father's Love and how a father and the
son created a national holiday tradition
we continue I agree it's pre-ordered now
thank you exciting thank you Ryan hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else